before we get into the video this video
is once again sponsored by you guys here
on YouTube and the extra support from my
patrons that you can see on screen just
know that any type of support whether
you're just watching the video
subscribing or supporting on patreon all
of it is greatly appreciated and leads
to Joy getting more tummy rubs treats
and toys I actually just had my computer
break on me this week along with one of
my monitors but I already had this video
about 90 percent of the way done so I
just finished it as best I could on my
really slow laptop we've got a new
computer on the way so expect higher
quality videos very soon we're growing
the channel every single day and we're
quickly on the road to a hundred
thousand subscribers that is an absolute
dream come true for me so thank you guys
very much with all that said let's get
into the video
so it's been a while since I've talked
about radon in a video this is mainly
because I thought there wasn't much else
to say about him he's a living legend
who battled against the Stars themselves
and actually won he was well loved by
his followers and was a devout follower
himself not just to the golden order but
his Warrior Idol Godfrey which makes a
lot of sense because of Godfrey's Legacy
as a warrior where he and his army would
battle against anyone who defied the
greater will and would always come out
Victorious so victorious in fact that
there was none left in the lands between
to fight against because of this they
lost their purpose and queen America
decided to banish Godfrey and his
Warriors and took away their guidance of
Grace which made them the very first
tarnished and like I said Godfrey was
radon's Idol and we could see this from
his Golden Lion armor set which is
branded with Godfrey's lion companion
Suraj maybe this is why radon took such
a liking to animals especially his
beloved horse Leonard a also is it
Leonard or Leonard I've had so many
people comment on the last radon video
that it's Leonard and I saw vazi video
also said Leonard so whatever vati video
says must be true I guess but when I
think of Elden ring I think of the
knights during the Middle Ages and stuff
like that where I'm pretty sure there
was King Leonard somewhere in there or
Knight Leonard I don't know but you guys
let me know what you think but as radon
Grew Older he also grew rapidly in size
but he still wanted to ride his trusty
Steed into battle so to do that radon
learned gravity magic in order to hover
slightly above Leonard as to not crush
him so why does Radon grow so much in
size well it could be because radnan has
some genetic traces to that of the
Giants when Godfrey battled against and
defeated the Giants the last remaining
giant put a curse on Queen America this
curse changed the color of her hair to
red to Brand her with the signature red
hair of the Giants in defiance of this
America counter cursed the last giant to
tend to the forge of the Giants for all
of eternity now it is theorized that
this is how radagon came to be America
obviously didn't want this curse so it's
possible that the greater will or
America herself manifested radagon in
order to rid her of this Giant's curse
the golden order seems to be very big on
appearances and he blemishes stains or
differences to that of their perfect
order are snuffed out very quickly a
great example of this are the omen Twins
morgot and Moog who were born as Omens
and were immediately at Birth banished
and Shackled to the sewers below the
capital city they are seen as stains in
comparison to the golden order so they
just get rid of that stain even if they
were born from royalty itself so to get
rid of this red-haired stain America or
the greater will manifested radagon from
the body of Queen America herself so
that she could keep her flowing golden
hair and radagon would take on this
red-haired curse and as we all know
eventually radagon met ranala in battle
and they fell quickly in love radagon
renounced his lust for battle and went
on to have three children with ranala
pray to Reichard General radon and lunar
princess Ronnie all of which seem to
have been born with red hair just like
their father we see this mostly from
radon obviously but traces of red can be
seen on Ronnie's body at the top of the
carrion Divine Tower as for Reichard we
don't really know what color his hair
was because you know he's a giant
gluttonous snake now
but like we were saying this could be
why radon grows rapidly in size he has
some traces of giant within his genetics
so this could be why he grows so large
again we don't know if reichardt was as
big as radon or was growing like him but
if we look at Ronnie's body again it
seems larger than most Melania could
also have of traces of the giant
genetics as she is also very large in
size at least in comparison to US this
is also suggested from some slight
dialogue from Kenneth height where he
describes to us a battle between Melania
and godric where apparently godric made
fun of melania's blouse and then Kenneth
height calls her a big girl then he
insulted Melania lost to her in battle
only to lick her boots rather than die
like a man
has she no shame the big girl's blouse
this makes sense that godric would make
fun of her for this since he is so
devout to the golden order maybe making
fun of those giant genetics Millennia
may have but a giant question I've asked
since I first started playing the game
is why does Radon hold the stars at Bay
why did he battle the stars to begin
with was he simply testing his own
gravitational power is he trying to
intimidate his opponents by doing so
this all could be a part of the reason
but I believe Rodan is holding back not
just the stars but much more there's
been this long-term theory that when
Ronnie discarded her great Rune he also
planned to kill her own two fingers
every demigod was given their own two
fingers by the greater will we can see
each of their fingers at their
corresponding Divine Towers all of which
except for Ronnies EG tells us that the
fate of the carrion royal family is
Guided by the stars as is the fate of
Lady Ronnie first Heir in the carrion
Royal line but General radon is the
Conqueror of the stars who stood up to
the swirling constellations halting
their movement in a smashing Victory and
so if General radon were defeated the
Stars would once again resume their
movement as would lady Ronnie's Destiny
so what does it mean when EG says that
Ronnie's fate is Guided by the stars for
a while I sort of thought this just
meant radon held time in place the Stars
wouldn't move meaning that the planet
wouldn't move either but obviously this
doesn't make much sense because there's
a clear night and day cycle and we can
also change the time of day whenever we
wish so that theory is out the window
unless the time of day and the movement
of the stars and the rotation of the
planet are just different in the lands
between that's definitely a long shot
Theory but what makes more sense is that
radon isn't holding back just the stars
but also Ronnie's two fingers in order
for Ronnie to completely rid herself of
all imperian influence she would need to
kill her own two fingers she's already
discarded her body in the ritual during
the night of black knives where her body
and Godwin's Soul were killed her spirit
is free and inherits the doll that
resembles her former Mentor Rena once we
defeat radon the Stars start their
movement once again and we can see a
huge explosion when a shooting star
falls out of the sky which opens up the
secret entrance to nocron the Eternal
City we need to go there in order to
obtain the Finger Slayer blade and give
it to Ronnie the item description of the
blade says the hidden treasure of the
Eternal City of nocron a blade said to
have been born of a corpse this
blood-drenched fetish is proof of the
high treason committed by the Eternal
City and symbolizes its downfall cannot
be wielded by those without a fate but
is said to be able to harm the greater
will and its vassals so Ronnie needed
the Finger Slayer blade in order to kill
her two fingers I believe that radon of
this plant somehow and radon may not be
a full follower of the greater will
since America banished his Idol Godfrey
from the lands between however he
obviously doesn't want the golden order
to be completely destroyed which is what
Ronnie wishes to do Blythe and EG both
willing to give too much to me yet
they both understand
what lieth beyond the dark path that I
must betray everything
and read the world of what came before
so Rodan took Ronnie's two fingers and
placed them Among the Stars maybe this
is why we can see a faint resemblance of
a great Rune when we look closely at the
moon this is what EG means when he
refers to Ronnie's fate being Guided by
the Stars we need to defeat radon in
order for him to release Ronnie's two
fingers so that she can slay them to be
then completely free from the influence
of the greater will we can find Ronnie
at the end of her questline deep within
a crater under the Cathedral of
manicellus there are Starlight shards
spread all over this area as well and
it's entirely possible that Ronnie's two
fingers crash down to the lands between
after we defeated radon the crater
itself and the destruction of the
cathedral also suggests that something
definitely crashed down through this
area we can find Ronnie with her two
fingers at the bottom of this Crater
where there is a clear and deep cut
through her two fingers where Ronnie
likely use the Finger Slayer blade to
finally kill her two fingers Ronnie's
doll sits idle in the spot until her
consort whoever that may be just so
happens to be us gives her the dark moon
ring the Ring's description reads
symbolic of a cold oath the ring is
supposed to be given by lunar princess
Ronnie to her consort Ronnie is an
empyrean meaning her consort with by
right earn the title of Lord a warning
is engraved within whoever thou mayest
be take not the ring from this place the
Solitude beyond the night is better mine
alone so this kind of suggests that
Ronnie doesn't really care either way if
someone like us became her consort and
then became Lord alongside with her
she's wanting to usher in an entirely
New Era and change what has been under
the influence of the greater will
whether we join her or not doesn't make
a difference to her but at least we
aren't technically maidenless anymore so
that's great she leaves her doll here
just in case we do wish to take on the
role as her consort we give her the ring
and she's sort of surprised that it was
us who would go all of this way for her
and what she desires
who would become my Lord
perhaps I needn't have warned Thee I am
pleased however
thou art a fit in Choice during Ronnie's
ending we can see the new era of
darkness she ushers in under the power
of the full moon there seems to be a lot
of mistranslations about what this
exactly means but what I think is the
main thing to understand about Ronnie's
ending and what her fate and destiny
truly is is that what Ronnie wants is to
change the world and get rid of the
greater Will's influence
so hopefully this video helped you guys
understand a bit better why radon was
holding back the stars and how Ronnie's
fate was tied to it another special
thank you to my patrons who helped
support this channel they get early
access to videos with no ads at all so
if you're interested in supporting the
Channel with some pretty cool benefits
check out my patreon which is linked in
the description along with all of my
other socials I'd appreciate it if you
gave them a follow thank you all for
watching the video and I will see you in
the next one take care
[Music]